- remarkable British restaurants
but only one can win a place in the
semi-finals
okay um I invited both you here today to
blow me away for one restaurant to excel
um I didn't get that no because I got
both freshens excelling in a big way and
it's amazing to see that kind of
performance in what my mind is one of
the most exciting categories but the joy
of watching and tasting what you've just
done in there has now become a nightmare
on a personal front because I have to
eliminate one of you
and put one of you through to the
semi-final so I thought well which dish
would I put on my lunch menu tomorrow
morning I came at the decision both the
dishes would sit there that's what I'm
faced with right now so the winner is
not based on one dish
because if it was both of you will be
going through think of the journey I
turn up with a coach 30 diners come
swooping in causes havoc and it's the
biggest pain-in-the-ass that any Russian
could ever wish for
I then film you undercover by sending an
awkward secret diner to turn the place
upside down to see how you handle that
kind of pressure here's my question
which restaurant would I prefer to
return to West as would I go to that
intimate stunning family-run Michelin
star done with charm
or would it be the Sheffield I suppose
balls of steel because it is run with a
heartbeat that is missing the lot of
Russians tough very tough
it is so hard you've got no idea
the restaurant going through to the
semi-final based on everything I've seen
is
last time congratulations
that was for me one of the toughest most
different decisions I've ever made but
that this was unique and don't stop
cooking like that yeah going out this
stage as far as I'm concerned makes us
you know worse the second best british
restaurant in the competition so you
know we're carry on we do we do what we
do at a restaurant and you know keep the
customers happy and that's that's the
main thing guys well done
really well done yeah phenomenal he
pulled out the subs there today and it
worked yeah good job well done well done
well done it's just amazing it's
fantastic dream come true it's proved a
point to us for and to a lot of the
people that are expecting a lot from us
and thank god we've actually come true
and we've made it with that kind of
determination that's where the future of
British cooking is up there in Sheffield
but right now this competition only
gonna get tougher and I hope they don't
let me down